[MUSIC PLAYING]
PATRICK CLARY: All righty,
welcome, everybody.
Woo, that's right.
We're here to talk today
about accessibility, great.
So my name's Patrick Clary,
I'm a product manager
on accessibility here at Google,
and I'll be kicking things off.
We also have a great group of
presenters from different areas
across Google with
me here today.
And there's a few things
that I want you to take away
with you as you leave today.
The first one is why
designing for accessibility
is really so important
and benefits our users.
And this isn't just
users with the disability
or an accessibility
need, but I want
to get across that this
actually helps all users.
The second thing
you'll learn about
is accessibility on Android.
You'll hear about what's
coming in Android O,
and you'll see some awesome
new demos of these things.
And then third is tips on
user research for users
who have an accessibility need.
You'll hear about this, and
you'll also see an inside look
with a couple of examples on
things we've done at Google,
how we perform research on a
couple of different products.
So very exciting.
So first, why accessibility?
So accessibility
is something that
is near and dear to my heart.
But I want to give you a few
reasons why it's important--
and I'm speaking
to the developers--
why it's important to
developers to consider, as well.
So here's a metric that I
actually find very compelling.
One in five people will have a
disability in their lifetime.
This is just a
staggering number.
So addressing accessibility
can have a direct benefit
on these users.
It's a huge benefit.
It's actually a life
changing benefit.
So for these users, it
actually means the difference
with connecting to
friends, family,
it's really taking
advantage of the technology
that mainstream users
really use and enjoy.
The second, as I mentioned,
is that designing
for accessibility really
benefits all users.
And let me give you
a couple examples.
So first, think about
designing a product that's
meant for a blind or
a low vision user.
So when you're doing
this, you actually
help users that might just
have their eyes occupied.
So perhaps they're
driving, they're
looking at another screen,
they're not looking directly
at their Android device.
Another example is
designing for a user that
might have a motor impairment.
So an example would be a tremor.
This is an impairment
that affects
their use of a touch screen.
It makes it difficult for
them to use a touchscreen.
So designing effectively
for these users
actually benefits mainstream
users who otherwise,
they just can't use
their touchscreen.
Maybe they're holding groceries,
maybe they're cooking,
but they can't use their
touchscreen effectively.
And when you think
about it this way,
designing for
accessibility is really
about designing for the widest
possible range of abilities
within the widest possible
range of situations.
It's not really about
designing for disabilities,
it's about designing
for all users.
So where does Android fit in?
So in Android, we have a series
of settings, APIs, and services
for accessibility.
So settings, these
really allow users
to customize how their device
looks and feels, right?
APIs allow developers
to build out their apps
in ways that meet the needs of
users who have accessibility
needs, and also allows us to
build accessibility services.
So an accessibility service
is a long running, privileged
program that runs on your
device that either changes
the way users consume the
content of your device,
or it changes the way they
interact with your device.
And we have a few here.
These are four that
Google has developed.
TalkBack, BrailleBack, Switch
Access, and Voice Access.
So TalkBack and
BrailleBack, these
are services designed
for users who
are blind or have low vision.
TalkBack is our screen reader.
What this allows users
to do is basically
interpret the content of their
device through an audio stream.
So users will listen to what's
on their device using TalkBack.
BrailleBack is similar, but
instead of an audio stream,
the content goes to a
refreshable braille display.
This is a little
handheld braille device
where a user can scan
their fingers across it
and interpret the
content on the screen.
We also have Switch
Access and Voice Access.
These are two services
that are targeted to users
with motor impairments.
So for example, as I mentioned,
users that have a tremor.
These are users that typically
can't use a touch screen.
So with Switch Access
and Voice Access,
we actually provide
full Android control
without ever having
to touch the screen.
So with Switch Access,
users typically
use an adaptive switch device.
You'll see an example
of one of these later,
but this is a physical
hardware switch
that a user might have mounted
in front of them, mounted
to a wheelchair, and
they'll tap on the switch
to linearly scroll through
things on their device.
Voice Access actually
allows users to control
their device purely by voice.
So you'll issue
voice commands that
correspond to touch controls.
These are things like
scroll up, scroll down,
tap, Gmail, go home, et cetera.
So that's what we
have on Android.
For a deeper look into the
upcoming version of Android,
I'll hand it off
to Maya and Victor.
VICTOR TSARAN: Hello.
Thank you, Patrick.
My name is Victor
Tsaran, and I'm
a technical program
manager on the Android
accessibility services team.
For Android O, our
major focus was
to increase
productivity for users
of accessibility services.
In particular, we looked
at users who are blind
and vision impaired, and
use TalkBack screen reader,
we're introducing
accessibility APIs
to help developers who
develop accessibility services
for people with
physical disabilities.
Once such service you
guys already heard about
is called Switch Access.
Last but not least, we're
introducing a new accessibility
service which will
help people with print
and learning disabilities to
read information on the screen.
But let me start with new
features for talk back.
The first feature I
would like to talk about
is called accessibility volume.
Behind the fancy words
is an ability for someone
who is blind or vision
impaired or specifically
uses TalkBack screen reader
to adjust the volume of speech
independently from the
volume of media, for example,
when watching a YouTube
video or listening to music.
We're doing this by introducing
a new audio stream in O
we call the
accessibility stream.
As a developer of an
accessibility service,
what that means
to you is that you
will have to request
this feature when writing
your accessibility service.
Otherwise it is not
available to you.
So let me show you how
this feature works.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Device unlocked.
Three-- home.
Pixel-- overview.
Overview.
Settings.
VICTOR TSARAN: I will
dismiss this guy.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Set-- dismiss--
YouTube-- Settings.
Dismiss YouTube--
open YouTube app--
YouTube.
Showing items one to 20--
207, the developer show
TL doctor 069 Google--
The Developers
Show TL doctor 069.
11k views.
VICTOR TSARAN: So here's
a typical situation.
I'm trying to
listen to talk back,
and this thing is
talking back at me.
Oh my God, I can't
hear anything.
AUTOMATED VOICE: More button.
VICTOR TSARAN: What
I can do right now,
I can completely shut off
the volume of the video--
AUTOMATED VOICE: Like
this video, more button.
VICTOR TSARAN: And I can
still hear it talk back.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Like this--
more-- Google App--
024-- Google D--
Up next, autoplay.
VICTOR TSARAN: So this is
essentially how this works.
So TalkBack user is now able to
adjust the volume of the speech
independently from
the media volume.
AUTOMATED VOICE: 100-- 035 of--
YOUTUBE VIDEO: More details
and links are on the--
AUTOMATED VOICE: 100 expand.
YOUTUBE VIDEO: Chrome 59
beta is now available--
VICTOR TSARAN:
Incidentally, you will also
notice that there is now a new
accessibility volume slider
at the top of the screen.
So that, again, allows you,
if you're a visual user,
you can adjust this slider
as well from the volume tray.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Rewind.
Pause video.
Play video.
Home screen one of two.
VICTOR TSARAN: So
the next feature
I would like to
talk about has to do
with new gestures for TalkBack.
We many of the new
Android devices
use a fingerprint sensor at
the back of their device.
So we decided, why not
utilize the fingerprint sensor
for additional gestures to
allow TalkBack users activate
some of the favorites
of their features?
So we are introducing an ability
for accessibility service
such as TalkBack to
utilize fingerprint sensor.
The gestures
available to the user
are swiping left,
right, up, or down.
These gestures are
assignable, so the user
can decide what
TalkBack features
each gesture will launch.
Again, as a developer of
an accessibility service,
you will have to request
a special flag in order
to be able to take advantage
of fingerprint gestures.
Fingerprint gestures
work only on O devices.
I just wanted to point that out.
And let me show
you how this works.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Device unlocked.
3:10 PM.
Home screen one of--
inbox, Chrome, camera.
VICTOR TSARAN: So I'm going to
attempt something very brave.
I'll take a selfie.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Camera.
Camera.
VICTOR TSARAN: And I'll be
using fingerprint gestures
to do that.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Photo gallery.
Shutter.
Switch to front camera.
Switch to back camera.
One face, right,
with 50% of screen.
Very close.
Zero faces.
Shutter.
Photo taken.
Photo gallery.
One face, center,
with 50% of screen.
Very close.
Home screen one of two.
VICTOR TSARAN:
Thank you very much.
These are the
fingerprint gestures
on Android O for accessibility.
The next feature I
would like to talk about
is multi-lingual support.
One of the things we
realized since Android
has been used so much
outside of the US,
we badly need to support
international users.
And in O, we're introducing
an ability for the Google text
to speech engine to
automatically recognize
languages that are appearing
on the screen and switch
text to speech to speak in
that particular language.
If you're a developer
and you would
like to trigger language
automatic switching,
you have to wrap your
strings in locale spans
to trigger that change.
But before you get
excited, let me
show how actually the language
switching feature works.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Device unlocked.
3:11-- home, overview, overview.
Home, home.
Home screen-- inbox,
messages-- inbox.
Inbox.
Remember-- subject,
beautiful day.
Remember to.
From Kara-- to me.
May 11th, more menu.
Hi there.
Come-- hi there.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK, so
my lovely wife likes
to pull little jokes at me.
Well, in this particular
case, this is not a joke.
She sent me a message
a few days ago
try to invite me for dinner.
And she does a lot
of things in style.
So in this particular
case is no exception.
So she decided to send me a
message in four languages.
Because, you know,
we're so cool, right?
So let's see how TalkBack deals
with this particular situation.
AUTOMATED VOICE: More menu.
Hi there.
Comment lost-- hi there.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Let's have dinner tonight.
VICTOR TSARAN: OK.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE] Thank you.
So luckily, both of us can
speak all those languages,
so I was able to
understand what she said.
So the languages were French,
Polish, Ukrainian, and Chinese,
just for the information.
And the last feature
we'd like to talk about
is the new
accessibility shortcut.
For quite a bit of time, users
have been asking us for ability
to turn off their
favorite accessibility
service regardless of
which screen they're on.
So they wanted a shortcut
key that they can press
and the search service
will toggle on and off.
For example, if a
blind person walked
into the store that
sold Android phones,
they wanted to be able to launch
TalkBack and start exploring
the phone to decide
whether this is something
they wanted to purchase or not.
Well, in O we're introducing
this accessibility shortcut.
By default it's configured
to launch TalkBack.
However, it can be
reconfigured to launch
any of the available
accessibility services
on your device.
I want to point out that
this works on any screen
even after you access
the Setup Wizard.
So once the shortcut
is configured,
it will be available to
the user at all times.
As a developer of an
accessibility service,
you will have to request
this feature at runtime
when your service runs.
Otherwise it is not
available to you.
So it's only available to
accessibility services.
And as you can guess, the demo
is going to be pretty simple.
So I'll show how this works.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Home.
VICTOR TSARAN: All
I have to do right
now is press two volume
keys at the same time.
And accessibility
service is off.
If I press them again,
AUTOMATED VOICE: Talk back on.
Inbox.
VICTOR TSARAN: That's it.
And that's how the
accessibility shortcut works.
[APPLAUSE]
So as you can imagine, I
just scratched the surface.
There's much more
coming up, but I
would like Maya to talk about
these other exciting services
and APIs.
Thank you.
MAYA BEN ARI: Thank you, Victor.
Thank you, Victor,
for the lovely demos.
My name is Maya Ben Ari, I'm
a product manager on Android
accessibility.
The next set of feature
we're going to talk about
are new APIs to framework
to support new accessibility
functionality.
We're adding
continuous gesture API.
In Android Nougat,
we added an API
to allow performing gestures
on behalf of the user.
In Android O, we are extending
this API to make it easier
to perform continuous gestures.
What does it mean?
Is that, for example,
it will be easier
for users using a wheelchair
mouse or a hat tracker
to perform gestures such as
drag and drop, text selection,
answering phone calls, and
zooming in and out of maps.
The next feature I'm
very excited about,
it's called the accessibility
button in the navigation bar.
What we added here is a
new accessibility button
to the right of
the navigation bar
to quickly invoke context
dependent accessibility
features.
Let's give an example.
Right now we had magnification.
So a user using
magnification can triple
tap to magnify the screen.
However, some users find
it challenging to perform
the triple tap gestures.
In Android O, we are
adding an alternative
to invoke magnification.
So let me show you
how this works.
So I have the
accessibility button
the bottom right of the screen.
I can simply tap the button.
And if I tap anywhere
on this screen,
I will magnify the content.
Now I can move this
around using two fingers,
and if I want to demagnify
it, I will just press
the accessibility button again.
Back to the slides.
Now, this is
optionally supported
by developer for devices with
software-rendered navigation
bar.
At the button will
be shown there
only if there is an
accessibility service
or feature that supports
it and is turned on.
The next set of feature are for
people with print disabilities.
Print disabilities
are people who have
difficulty of reading text.
Those include people with
dyslexia, far sighted,
low vision, illiterate,
or even people who just
want to learn a new language.
We recently launched a service
called Select to Speak.
Select to Speak is
part of TalkBack 5.2.
And what the service does is it
vocalized content on the screen
by allowing users to
select elements to read.
Now, this service is available
from lollipop MR1 and up.
Now, this is an example of
how Select to Speak works.
You can see a floating
action button.
Then the user can
either tap an element
or marquee select
elements to read,
and the content will
be read out loud.
In Android O, we're adding
additional functionality
for Select to Speak,
including reading
the whole page,
advanced controller
to move backward and
next, or adjust the speed.
We add also word
level highlighting,
and we integrated this
service into the setup wizard.
Now let me show
you how it works.
So I have here the
accessibility button,
and if I long press on
the accessibility button,
I can show that also
I have a service which
uses this button
called Select to Speak.
I will select that one.
And if I will tap
the button again,
then I will be shown
a controller bar.
At this point I can drag and
drop or move the controller bar
on the screen.
Now I can either support the
functionality I already have--
for example, I can marquee
select, or tap an element--
AUTOMATED VOICE: Maps, clock.
MAYA BEN ARI: And it
will be read out loud.
Now what I can also have
is continuous reading.
AUTOMATED VOICE: 69
degrees Fahrenheit.
Wednesday, may 17.
Maps, clock, Play
Store, Chrome, Drive.
MAYA BEN ARI: Close
down that one.
Now, we also have
this Select to Speak,
it can read the
whole page, and it
can read the whole sentences.
And I can go backward and
forward with the sentences,
and also increase and
decrease the speed
and by pressing the
plus and minus button.
Let me show you how it works.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Navigate up.
Select to Speak.
Settings.
When Select to Speak is on,
you can tap specific items
on your screen to-- first
tap the-- then you can--
(SPEEDING UP) tap a specific
item, like text or an image.
Drag your finger
across the screen
to select multiple items.
Items.
Tap the Play button
to hear everything.
MAYA BEN ARI: Thank you.
And this is Select to Speak,
available in Android O
and with TalkBack 5.2.
The next section
is about testing.
We'd like to make Android
more accessible for everyone,
and developer are a crucial
part of this mission.
You can develop
better experience
for people with
disability, but a lot of it
has to do with how you test
your app for accessibility.
In the next section,
I'm going to talk
about manual and automated
testing for accessibility.
Now let's start
with manual testing.
The first thing
that you want to do
is you want to get
familiar [INAUDIBLE]
yourself, and understand how
the experience work with Android
accessibility services,
specifically with TalkBack
and Switch Access.
So download TalkBack, turn
it on, and cover your eyes,
and try to go through the
experience in your app.
You'd like to notice whether
your app is representing
correctly the
content for TalkBack.
For example, maybe you
have unlabeled bottles,
or maybe you're missing
context description,
or maybe you have controls
which are hard to interact with.
Pay special attention
for issues that
may impact users
efficiently while you
are performing common flows.
Now, if it works
well with TalkBack,
it will also likely work well
with BrailleBack and Select
to Speak.
Because what you're
doing is you are actually
testing your output.
You are testing whether you
are representing correctly
your content to the
accessibility services.
The next thing that
you want to test
is you want to test
with Switch Access.
As Patrick mentioned,
Switch Access
is a service targeted for
user with motor impairment who
has difficulty interacting
with their device.
In that case, the user
connects something which
is called an adaptive switch.
This is an example of
an adaptive switch.
Now, the adaptive switch
can contain two buttons,
less, or more.
And in that case,
the user can map
one button for a next
operation, and one for an enter.
Now, if you don't have
an adaptive switch
you can just connect
an external keyboard
and map your keyboard buttons
to specific activities
in Switch Access.
Now, after you do that, you
want to go through common flow,
and you want to note whether
Switch Access interacts
correctly with your app UI.
Now, if it works well
with Switch Access,
it will also likely work
well with Voice Access.
Because what you're
doing at that point,
you are testing your app input.
With Switch Access
and TalkBack, you
are testing both your
app output and input.
Now, testing with Switch
Access and TalkBack
is the best way for you to
understand the experience
that you are providing for
users with different needs.
But this is not
all, because there
are multiple other features
available on the platform,
including magnification,
enlarged text.
To facilitate the
accessibility testing,
we also provide a tool which is
called Accessibility Scanner.
Accessibility Scanner
is a standalone app
which you can download
free from the Play Store.
And the app is targeted for
app developer and QA testers,
and it suggests ways
for you to improve
the accessibility of your app.
How you can use it?
Just download it, turn
it on, and then you
will see a floating action
button on your screen.
Bring the UI you are
interested into the foreground,
press the button, and
then Accessibility Scanner
will analyze the UI and will
show some suggestion of how
to improve your accessibility.
And in this example,
it's shown examples
for improving your
text contrasts.
We shipped this app
in March last year,
and we're very happy to
announce that in the last year,
user used Accessibility
Scanner to find over
1 million opportunities
for improving their app
accessibility.
Definitely check it out and
download Accessibility Scanner
from the Play Store.
And a bit about
automated testing.
We also created accessibility
testing framework
to allow you to perform
automated testing.
Accessibility Testing Framework
is an open source library
that provides that
provides runtime evaluation
on real Android UI post tracks.
We integrated this
testing framework
into two common test
frameworks called
Robolectric and Espresso.
If you're already using
those testing framework,
you can simply turn
on accessibility test
functionality within
those framework,
and then you might see
some of your test start
failing because they could
have an improved accessibility.
Lastly, we launch a new
section about accessibility
on developer.android.com,
and this
can help you guide to better
understand how to implement
accessibility in your app.
Specifically, we have a
page about testing your app
accessibility.
In general, we recommend a
balance between manual testing
and automated testing for
making your app accessible.
With this page,
the page summarize
how you can develop
a holistic test
strategy that improve both
manual and automated testing.
But with all this testing,
there is no better way
than interacting
with actual user
and conducting user research.
And for that, Astrid
and Melissa are going
to tell you all about that.
ASTRID WEBER: Thank you, Maya.
I'm Astrid Weber, I work
on user experience research
for accessibility
engineering at Google.
MELISSA BERNHART: And
I'm Melissa Bardhart,
and I'm a UX
researcher on Android.
ASTRID WEBER: So what
is actually UX research,
and why do we need it?
Imagine you have a
dream of opening a bar.
I mean, how many of
us haven't had it
at some point in our lives?
You have these cool design ideas
for the interior of your bar,
you know exactly what you want
to serve on your drinking menu,
and you really know that the
music you're going to play
is what you basically
have at home,
and you play yourself the most.
Basically, while you're
building your bar,
you're imagining how perfect a
bar could be if it would just
be the perfect place
for someone with exactly
the same tastes like yourself.
Basically, your users, they
are just like yourself, right?
Chances are, unfortunately,
that your bar might be empty,
and your business idea might
be failing like over 50%
of all bars and restaurants are
failing within the first year
of their existence.
And I'm pretty sure that
all the owners of these bars
and restaurants really wanted
to create a good experience,
and really made
choices that they
would have taken themselves.
And this brings us up to the
importance of user experience
research and design, for
restaurants and bars,
but also for
technology development.
Because unfortunately, the
failure rate among startups
is at 90%, which is much
higher than actually
the one around restaurants.
At the same time, research
shows that if you are testing
your own assumptions and your
user needs often and early,
your chances
increase so much more
that you will end up with a well
rated app and satisfied users.
Which brings us very
close to the definition
of actual and objective
UX research, which really
is all about changing your
own perspective to that
of your users to
understand their needs,
including all the
accessibility needs.
User research focuses on
understanding user behaviors,
needs, and motivations for
various research techniques.
It is the process of
understanding the impact
of design on an audience.
Now that we have a
common understanding
of the concept of UX research,
what does it actually entail?
UX research is a set
of research methods
that can help you during the
whole process of your product
development cycle.
UX research methods, such as
field studies, interviews,
or competitive
analysis, are very well
suited in the beginning of
your product development work,
because they are
especially useful in order
to understand how
technology usage works,
and how new innovative
fields work.
Once you have
decided what to build
and you have a first
prototype, research methods
such as usability studies,
participatory design exercises,
or remote research
are actually really
useful for you to
understand what works
and what doesn't work in
the hands of your users.
And lastly, once your product
is out there in the market,
you really want to understand
how it's doing, right?
Research methods such as
log analysis, diary studies,
as well as remote
testing, really
help you at that stage of
your product development
to understand how the app
is doing in the market,
and if people really like it.
And with that, I hand
it over to Melissa,
has a very concrete
example for you
from our recent accessibility
Android development on O.
MELISSA BARNHART: All right.
Thank you, Astrid.
So today I'd like to
show you exactly how
accessibility
research has informed
the design process for Android.
Let's take the
example of settings.
We want all users to be able
to easily access and understand
settings that are
relevant to them,
including users with
accessibility needs.
Here we have a screenshot of
the accessibility settings
page for Android N. When
planning for Android O,
we had some assumptions
about this page.
Firstly, we felt that it
was a bit unorganized,
making it difficult for
users to find what they need.
Secondly, we questioned
whether or not
categories like
services and system
had any real meaning to users.
So we turned to research
to check our assumptions
and make more informed
design decisions.
We used two research
methods, usability studies
and intercepts.
And as Astrid just
mentioned, these methods
are well suited for the
design develop stage.
So we started with
usability studies.
In these studies, we invited
people with visual impairments
to our offices and
prompted them to interact
with the accessibility
settings page you just saw.
Now, we immediately
observed some issues.
Specifically, the
participants could not always
find the settings we
asked them to find.
And even when they did,
they weren't always sure
what those settings would do.
Now, our approach
to this research
was iterative, so we'd
learn things in one study,
adjust the design, and then
retest the adjusted design
in the next study.
But we wanted to hear from a
wider, more diverse audience.
So we went to a conference.
In January, we attended the
Assistive Technology Industry
Association Conference
in Orlando, Florida.
With just a clipboard,
pen, paper, and phone,
we approached
conference attendees
and asked them for 10 minutes of
feedback on our latest designs.
These intercepts allowed us
to gather a lot of feedback
in a relatively
short time frame.
In just two days, we
talked to 15 people
with visual, cognitive, and
motor impairments, as well as
AT professionals and educators.
As a result of this
research, we verified
a lot of our assumptions
and fine tuned our designs.
And here's a sneak peek at
the accessibility settings
page for Android
O. On the right,
you'll see that we're
introducing categorizations
by utility.
So instead of categories
like services and system,
you'll find categories like
screen readers, and display.
Also we've added colorful icons
to make Android services pop.
Lastly, below each setting we've
included a short description
to explain what
the setting does.
Now accessibility
research helped
guide this design approach,
and it can help you, too.
So if you want to build
products for the widest possible
audience and genuinely
improve people's lives,
consider incorporating
accessibility research
into your current process.
I promise you don't need fancy
equipment or a big budget
to get started.
Think creatively about
how you can talk to users
with accessibility needs.
Maybe you attend a
conference like we did,
maybe reach out to a local
organization or university
or maybe you have a friend
with dyslexia or colorblindness
who would be willing
to try your app
and give you 15
minutes of feedback.
Try to include one person
with accessibility needs
in your next research study
and see what you learn.
The difference between zero
and even a little bit of data
is astounding.
And with that, I will hand
it back over to Astrid.
ASTRID WEBER: Thanks, Melissa.
Those of you working on
consumer facing apps hopefully
already marked
your calendars now
to conduct some accessibility
research as soon as you're back
in the office.
Those of you who work on
developer facing applications
might be wondering, but
what about my target group?
Well, the good news is they can
also benefit from UX research.
And we have an example of our
very own Accessibility Scanner
app about how the
UX research really
helped us to develop
a better application.
We tested Accessibility Scanner
with designers, test engineers,
developers, and
product managers.
We did the early
stage prototyping
with some paper marks.
In addition to that, we
also tested the name itself.
Yes, you heard correctly.
Accessibility Scanner was
not born with that name.
We had a long list of options.
But rather just following our
own intuition or preference,
we asked our users
in interviews.
Because we wanted to
understand which name would
be most memorable,
and what people
are associating with
each of the options.
Thanks to UX
research, we also made
some visual and
interaction design changes
to the application.
One of the visual
design changes entails
that we do not
use colors anymore
to distinguish the kind
of issues being detected.
Having a diverse
sample of users really
helped us there, because
the colorblind participants
of our study clearly signal
to us that they felt left out
of the experience if you use
color because they could not
necessarily distinguish the
elements based on that factor.
We also improved the overall
flow of the application
by making it easy to just click
on any element of detection
and then get a short
description of the issue.
This way the application became
especially useful and usable
to those new to
accessibility testing.
And on that note,
I will hand it back
to Patrick with
our final thoughts
and an outlook on what's next.
PATRICK CLARY: All right.
Thank you, Astrid.
So I hope everyone's
inspired to go home, work,
look at your own products,
look at your own apps,
think about accessibility,
the benefit that it
can have on these users.
Along those lines, I
have a few challenges
to the developers
in the audience.
So the first one is,
familiarize yourself
with accessibility services and
these APIs that were mentioned.
So when you go home,
turn on TalkBack,
turn on Switch
Access, put yourself
in the shoes of these users
and run through your app,
see what things you uncover.
The second is to download
Accessibility Scanner.
Download it, it's very easy.
You can get it, you
can test your app.
Very easy to find
some low hanging
fruit, some quick and
easy ways to improve
the accessibility of your app.
And finally, think about
performing user research
with users that have
an accessibility need.
So find a family
member or friend,
someone in your community,
go to a conference,
sit with them as
they use your app,
and I bet you'll be surprised
with things you learn.
We have a few other
really interesting things
happening at Google
I/O for accessibility.
So we have a couple
other sessions.
Designing for the
Next Billion Users,
and Pragmatic Accessibility
tomorrow on stage 5.
We also have a sandbox
just back here.
This is your chance
to come talk to us,
learn more about
accessibility, see these demos,
speak to a Google or one on
one and get more information.
We also have on
Thursday at 6:30,
we have the Google Play
awards, and there'll
be an awesome award for the
best accessibility experience.
So I recommend you
check that out.
So with that, I'd like
to thank you and make
sure you keep in touch.
You can use her Twitter
handle, @googleaccess.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]